what's good welcome welcome to Market
takes I am your host Dion rabone
reporter at the Wall Street Journal
today today is a big day man if you've
been watching the markets if you've been
reading the headlines if you're paying
attention at all you know today is a big
day and we are breaking down some of the
Big Data this isn't data that normally
makes a lot of waves that investors are
normally talking about but retail sales
and PPI today have made some big moves
in the market we are going to explain
what happened what the data showed us
and how it all comes together with all
this news about Bank runs bank failures
the economy the market stocks bonds we
are breaking that all down right here on
Market takes listen first of all we're
going to show you what the reports show
we've got some charts up there so you
can actually see what's going on how
this data is moving we're going to break
that down for both retail sales and PPI
aka the producer price index AKA whole
sale prices AKA here's what businesses
are paying we're also going to talk
about the market reaction we're going to
go through the market stocks bonds we're
going to talk fed fund Futures we're
going to nerd out a little bit y'all
keep coming on the comments telling me
you want me to nerd out we're getting
into fed fun Futures today baby so be
careful what you wish for we're going
deep we also of course we're going to
talk about the market environment coming
in the economic environment coming in
what was happening around the world and
here in the US that made these reports
such an impactful uh release today we're
going to talk about all that of course
we're going to talk about these Bank
fears and Bank runs we're going to talk
a little bit about Credit Suisse uh so
you all know what's going on and of
course we're going to talk about the FED
expectations and how this influences the
FED because if you're not watching the
FED in central banks you're not an
investor right now go play Pokemon this
isn't for you anyway and of course we're
going to tell you what comes next and
what to watch for we're going to be
doing Market takes for the FED meeting
next week so I want you to be right here
but before that we got to get into to a
day and what happened so first let's
talk about U.S retail sales after the
biggest increase in close to two years
we saw a negative number on the retail
sales today's report showed negative
four percent point four percent excuse
me negative point four percent
contraction month over month and a 4.6
increase year over year so want to throw
this chart up here of retail sales and
here's what we're seeing now that number
on the far right of your screen there
that's the February number we got today
negative point four percent now when you
look back that January number that three
percent that could have suggested okay
maybe retail sales are starting to pick
back up maybe consumers are going out
spending again well now it looks like
we've got a bit of a theme look at
December look at November those are the
two months previous to that big spike up
and then you go back to September you
see another Decline and then you see
another decline a couple months before
that it's looking like we are seeing a
defined Trend now a trend of lower
numbers on those retail sales reports
right and and that could tell us that
consumers are starting to pull back
maybe they're starting to tap out maybe
consumers are saying these prices are
too high I'm pulling back that's bad
news for the overall economy but could
be good news for markets and good news
for the Federal Reserve so just wanted
to throw that up there to kind of
illustrate so you can see the overall
theme that we've been seeing over the
past year or two on retail sales now
this contraction really kind of puts
that January number as a bit of an
outlier and it tells us that we're
returning to that Trend that we saw
overall for retail sales being lower
being negative that's not a great thing
if you're running a business that's not
a great thing if you're out there trying
to sell your products so keep in mind
that this number for retail sales not
such a good thing it's good on the
inflation front not so good on the
recession front we'll be talking about
both of those here in just a minute
let's talk about PPI the producer price
index want to throw that chart up there
and now the price you the chart you just
saw for retail sales was month over
month the this is year over year and I
show the difference up there so that you
can see how prices are changing year
over year for the producer price index
businesses are paying about 4.6 that's a
4.6 growth year over year but what
you're not seeing in that chart of
overall price declines over the past
couple years our overall price increases
excuse me over the past couple years is
a 0.1 contraction month over month that
we saw for February from January in PPI
now this was well below expectations on
the year-over-year number the month over
month for core all of that stuff but
what you see there on your screen is a
very clear wave down from that Peak that
we saw in about July of this year we
have just come down and down and down
and why that matters is PPI is the
precursor for CPI so just wanted to put
that up on your screen to illustrate
kind of the overall trend and what
you're seeing is prices coming down for
businesses we know that businesses have
consistently passed those price
increases on the consumers and raise
prices very fast and actually raise
prices at a greater level than what
they're paying so when we see this come
down to 4.6 percent year-over-year
inflation on the PPI level for
businesses that likely means that
overall Consumer Price inflation can
continue to fall even further going to
get into some details for you just a
little bit like I said y'all ask me to
nerd out in the comments we're getting
into these details the core was 0.0 4.4
percent increase that is a big Miss core
was expected to rise 0.4 percent and 5.2
percent year over year just know that's
a big Miss on the core number the PPI
for goods which makes up about 31 of the
total was down was also negative point
two percent PPI for services down about
point one percent Services 67 percent
all those numbers mean is that services
are a bigger part of the economy about
two-thirds of this report and we're down
less than Goods why does that matter the
Federal Reserve has zoned in on Services
they they've said we're watching
Services because we know Goods prices
are coming down we've seen the ports
clearing up we've seen a lot of these
supply chain issues clear up now we're
worried about services and Services is
coming down less than less than overall
prices for for uh for goods but Services
is now only 3.8 percent on the year
that's a good sign when it comes to
inflation coming down so overall today's
reports were good news on the inflation
front we were seeing inflation coming
down moving back toward the fed's two
percent Target that's good news for
markets good news for investors good
news for business people here's where
things start to get a little sticky
actually you know getting a little ahead
of myself there is some more good news a
couple people in the comments yesterday
were really excited about egg prices I
got invited over for some omelets and
frittatas don't think I'm not going to
take y'all up on that but a big piece of
this report that I I don't know if
everyone caught my man Lou Breen over at
drw trading pointed this out to me he
says that over 80 percent of the
February decline eighty percent eight
zero in the in the index for final
demand Goods can be attributed to a drop
in prices for chicken eggs so chicken
egg prices remember everybody's been
complaining about egg prices egg price
is too high cardi B talking about
lettuce eggs oh my God this is crazy
it's on Twitter it's on your feed
everyone's saying egg prices aren't
crazy well egg prices fell off a cliff
this past month in February and they
dragged the overall prices for food down
and made a huge impact on the price for
final demand Goods that's big overall
this pushes this suggests that CPI could
be coming down in further months and
again we saw yesterday if you watched
the live stream yesterday if you didn't
go back and watch it after we're done
here but yesterday when we looked at CPI
we saw that shelter was a huge part
about 70 percent of the increase in
overall CPI and and that suggests well
shelter is a lagging indicator we know
shelter prices come in late and they can
be something that you know the Federal
Reserve is saying okay we see rent
prices coming down we see the prices
that people are paying for homes coming
down we think shelter prices are coming
down well that suggests again another
sign that inflation is coming back down
this is good news for the overall
economy so we've talked about the
economy in terms of inflation the other
big piece of that is recession and
recession fears and that looks to be
what's moving the market today so we're
going to check in on the overall Market
we're going to talk about stocks bonds
FX everything is moving in a big way
today we've got the S P 500 down about
1.3 percent right now NASDAQ is actually
down the least down about point nine
percent and the Dow is down 1.4 percent
real worries about the real economy
what's moving things right now obviously
Credit Suisse and bang fears and all
that stuff we're going to get into that
in just a minute but when we look out at
the market today we are seeing a
significant change in expectations for
the Federal Reserve if you look at the
short part of the yield curve we're
talking bonds you know how I love to
talk bonds now if you look at the yield
curve right now in the short dated place
that's three month bills six month bills
one year two year there has been a huge
just jumping off a cliff decline in the
in the yield of bonds we are seeing the
two-year note now down at 3.78 percent
well below four percent just a couple
weeks ago that was at five percent so we
have seen in just a matter of days
really weeks that we've gone down over a
hundred basis points on the two-year
yield that is a huge move the one year
down at about four point one one percent
uh and the three month at 4.79 basically
what the market is saying is they don't
expect the FED to raise rates anymore in
fact you're looking at a Cut Rate cut
expectations going forward as we look
out into the future
when we look at fed fun Futures the FED
fund Futures Market just yesterday just
a couple days ago had been pricing in a
50 basis point increase for the fed the
Fed was going to raise rates at twice
the rate they normally do now that's out
the window when you look out at the FED
fund Futures Market the market is saying
no we think not only is the Fed not
going to raise 50 basis points we don't
think they're going to raise 25 basis
points which was the normal pace for
about the past 20 years we think now
they're going to hold Pat not raise
rates at all zero percent move and
that's factored at 60 percent when you
get out to December of this year fed fun
futures for this year are projecting a
full one percent rate cut so they think
the FED is going to cut rates by a
hundred basis points after this day to
day that is huge that's big for stocks
bonds Commodities everything you can
think of because the market is now
saying we think this Fed rate hiking
cycle is over and we think they're going
to start having to cut rates into the
future that is big that suggested all
this trouble with the banks that we're
seeing is really playing a role and this
inflation data that we've seen yesterday
and today which says that inflation is
coming down that's going to move the fed
and we know the FED moves markets the
FED moves the economy the FED is
everything the FED really has taken
control of this economy since March of
2020 and they're expected to kind of
back off and eventually start moving in
the opposite direction so let's talk
about the overall Market coming in I
know y'all have heard about those Credit
Suisse headlines down about 25 percent
on the news
um let's take a look rather than just
talking about Credit Suisse as an
individual stock let's take a look at
the overall Bank stocks I want to throw
up here on your screen the KBW Bank
index we looked at this yesterday and
the huge move that you had seen over the
past few days right in just five days
the KBW Bank index was down about 20
over 20 percent in and that's more than
it's down year to date that's all that's
about two-thirds of the entire decline
over the past year and you saw a little
pickup yesterday was something of a
relief rally you saw First Republic jump
about 40 45 at the top of its rebound
you saw a lot of stocks moving higher
but overall when you see just that
little incremental pickup there at the
end of your screen that tells you that
Traders aren't all the way in that
there's still worry about a lot of these
Bank stocks and what we're seeing today
is that KBW Bank index is down another
three percent so just wanted to put that
up there to illustrate the market
sentiment and the market themes overall
investors do not buy the story that
banks are not in trouble we are seeing
worries about Banks and we are seeing
the FED expected to take action this is
all very big and very big news so listen
the inflation narrative we talked about
that PPI down big CPI was look like
looking like it's moving but that
shelter component suggests that it's got
further to go and we could see bigger
declines in the future the recession
narrative that's what's also pressed in
if consumers aren't buying things if
retail sales aren't Rising if they're
declining inflation is still rising at
about six percent according to the CPI
so if consumers if prices are rising at
six percent and consumers are buying or
spending less that's not a good sign for
the overall economy that's increasing
fears about recession that the economy
could be in trouble along with in
addition to some of these fears about
the banks because we know Sogo the bank
so goes the economy because the banking
structure is so written into and so
integral to the U.S financial markets
and the overall U.S economy you guys
remember 2008 not saying we're there not
saying we're there only saying that to
point out the importance of the banking
sector to the U.S economy so that brings
us to the fed the Federal Reserve
expectations from the market for them to
hold Pat not raise rates at their
meeting zero percent hike AKA no hike
um we are getting to the hard part the
easy part was for the FED to raise rates
because inflation was Rising right
inflation Rises feds got to raise rates
to get inflation now now we're getting
to a place where fed has decisions to
make we're actually going to see some
arguments some back and forth we're
likely to see some dissents in these
decisions made by the fomc the operating
Committee of the fed the decides policy
Barclays and Goldman Sachs both say the
FED is going to hike zero percent the
market had been disagreeing with them
factoring in about a 55 chance for a 25
basis point hike now that's off Market
says 60 says 60 no hike this month
they're not going to move after today's
data
um the bond market also when you look at
those big declines in the one year two
year the six month and the three month
those are all saying the fed's not going
to move we are not seeing those same
moves in the 10 year and the third year
in those long dated bonds and that's why
you're seeing what they call yield curve
compression or yield curve flattening
it's a bear flattening move if you want
to get super technical about it y'all
ask me to nerd out so we're nerding out
but we're seeing that bear flattening is
in yields on the shorter end of the
curve short dated bonds coming down way
faster than the long data that just
shows investors are saying the fed's not
going to move they're going to start
cutting rates and that is not even being
factored in as good news for the overall
economy real recession fears being
played out in the market listen the FED
has had some real problems with its
forward Guidance with its credibility
being taken seriously by the market next
week is a huge meeting for Fed chair
Jerome Powell and the fomc you're going
to want to watch that and you're going
to want to be right here for Market
takes we are going to be breaking it all
down march 22nd 4 P.M after markets
close we are going to be right here with
Market takes I hope you'll be with us
um the FED discount borrowing report is
out on Thursday be sure and watch that
because that's going to be big to tell
you what these banks are doing Michigan
consumer confidence that's out on Friday
be sure and watch that and be sure to be
here for Market takes next Wednesday
it's a week from today listen that's
going to do it for Market takes today
I'm your host Dion rabone I know you
could have been anywhere in the world
but you were here with me and I
appreciate that we'll be right back here
on Market takes next week I hope to see
you there and we'll do it again next
time